>> Jesse: NOT LETTING UP.
THE RUSSIANS ARE MOVING TOWARDS
DECAPITATING UKRAINE.
FOR MORE LET'S GO TO BILL.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON TO YOU, I WANT
TO SEE A LITTLE BIT OF THE MAP
BEHIND ME.
AS OF WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
MAJOR ATTACKS BETWEEN UKRAINIAN
MILITARY AND THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY.
THERE'S A BIG BATTLE APPEAR AT
CHERNOBYL.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE WON THAT
BATTLE.
THE BATTLE HERE AT NORTHWEST.
THAT IS STILL IN DISPUTE.
LOOKS LIKE THE UKRAINIANS
PUSHBACK ON THAT.
THIS IS ON THE UKRAINIAN SIDE OF
THE BORDER NOW.
WE ARE GETTING REPORTS OF FIERCE
UKRAINIAN RESISTANCE THERE AND
SOME RUSSIAN CASUALTIES AS A
RESULT.
NOW JESSE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE BORDER SO THIS IS IN RUSSIA.
THIS IS SATELLITE IMAGE FROM
TODAY.
FEBRUARY 24TH FROM THE MILITARY
INSTALLATION.
WHAT YOU CAN SEE HERE THE FIELD
HOSPITAL YOU'VE TENSE HERE OFF
TO THE LEFT, YOU'VE MILITARY
TRUCKS ON THE OTHER SIDE OFF TO
THE RIGHT.
YOU'VE ATTACK HELICOPTERS, MANY
OF THEM APPEAR AS WELL.
THIS IS A STAGING AREA FOR THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY.
AND THIS SATELLITE IMAGE YOU CAN
SEE 18 ATTACK HELICOPTERS,
LITTLE HARD TO SHOW UP ON SCREEN
THERE BUT I CAN CIRCLE THEM
HERE, AND THERE, HERE AND THERE.
AS WELL AS OVER HERE.
AND THEY ARE, AND ON THEY GO.
THIS IS CLEARLY A STAGING AREA
FOR THE RUSSIAN MILITARY ONE
MORE MAP TO SHOW YOU RIGHT NOW.
AND THIS IS IN THIS PART OF THE
COUNTRY.
WHERE IS THE RUSSIAN MILITARY
GOING AND HOW ARE THEY GOING AT
UKRAINE?
22 A LOT OF ANALYSTS, THEY
DESCRIBE THE BORDER HERE.
THIS IS THE FRIENDLY RUSSIAN
NEIGHBOR TO THE EAST.
REMEMBER, BELARUS ALLOWED
MILITARY INSTALLATIONS ON BEHALF
OF THE RUSSIAN MILITARY, MANY OF
THEM OVER THE LAST 60 DAYS IN
THE USE THOSE OVERNIGHT HOW TO
USE THEM, WHAT THEY DO?
DESCRIBED AS THE MOVE TO THE
NORTH WEST AND THE NORTHEAST OF
KYIV.
THEY HAVE NOT GONE A LOT OF
REPORTING.
THAT WAS AREA TAKEN OVER IN
2014.
CRIMEA WAS THE OTHER AREA AND
THUS THE THIRD AREA OF ATTACK
NOW FROM THE SOUTH AND TO THE
NORTH AND THAT APPEARS TO BE THE
INITIAL OF THE RUSSIAN MILITARY.
IT'S AFTER MIDNIGHT NOW IN KYIV
WE'LL SE